what's the closest you can get within
the rules and the rules are you're
allowed to add numbers together you're
allowed to subtract numbers you're
allowed to multiply numbers and you're
allowed to divide numbers you're allowed
to have powers but i'm actually not
using those because when you're writing
a program to do it they explode you get
these ridiculously big values and it's
just easier to not bother but they are
allowed I'm just not going to use them
and you're allowed to put brackets in to
choose the order so I'm going to put
some brackets there to symbolize that
and you're allowed to just bunch the
numbers together so if you look here
concatenation there you go well done
there you guys think that earlier today
they were you going to have a
concatenation theme today in fact you
could take these two videos that
involved concatenation and just play
them one after the other and so you
didn't bat an eye when three four five
six you like what hang on you didn't
think well what's the mathematical
operation you've done there to put them
in order you're just perfectly happy
that of course three four five six can
be there and so concatenations a strange
one there's no agreed symbol for
concatenation some people use two lines
some people use a plus in a circle some
people use like little dashes or dots
are all sorts of things i'm going to use
i tend to use the two lines right in to
be complete I probably should have put
in this picture if we go back to the
past to fix previous errors if I sing
more star I would have put three
concatenate for concatenate five
concatenate six and down here actually
done for concatenate three right you
know to be more fun so that is
concatenation is clearly allowed if we
just for some reason we never bother
spelling it up so what I'm going to do
is here's my almost but not good enough
attempt so gonna be a park of square
this is really cool right so you start
with 12 so one concatenate two to 12
then x 3 x 4 divide that by five
multiply it by six multiply it by seven
add on eight put that whole thing in
brackets and then multiply that
by nine okay so what does this equal
let's check that and we're close 10 9 58
mark with exactly if it equal 10 9 58 we
are on so here we go so one can catenate
to that's 12 x 3 x 4 / 5 x 6 x 7
equals okay so the whole thing there
plus 8 equals 1217 point 6 times 9
equals ten thousand nine hundred 58.4
that's that's not bad ten thousand nine
hundred if you say classic parker square
where you're in so much trouble Brady
laughs come on that's not bad right
that's as close as I can get within the
rules as initially I understood them man
what we'll do you think I'm not going
back a square on the screen runner okay
like a hashtag thanks for the quick a
day is unnecessary right okay anyway so
as long as you try to sell the t-shirt
again but do you know how many people
shop to my shows wearing Parker Square t
shirts unbelievable honor right anyway
so what's interesting about the
concatenation thing is it's never
explicitly stated to be able to look at
the start of the paper he talks a lot
about he loves plus product potentiation
two powers and brackets loves those he
will concede you can add in- and
division which you like the SEC they're
not as good as plus and multiplication
or products but they're okay and they're
allowed it he never explicitly says
concatenation all he does is in here he
goes you can add a and B multiplied a
and B powers of a and B oh and of course
AMV forming a number so all the ones in
here a lot of them do use concatenation
right from the beginning it's never
assumed you can't do that but it's never
used as a step during the calculation
it's only used in a setup of the numbers
that you then apply the other operations
to and I like that's a bit arbitrary it
should be a fully-fledged function if
you go include it you've got to include
it and so I found one x two concatenated
with three plus in brackets
four times 5 times 6 and then that so 4
times 5 just you know we're going with
this that's going to be 20 x 6 is 120 but
then 120 is concatenated with seven so
now you do the calculation first and
then you concatenate with another digit
then you add on an eight and that whole
thing you multiply by nine shall we
check it let's just do this simplify it
to their equals k 1 x 23 that's just 23
i think we're all quite happy with that
plus in brackets that's going to be 4
times 5 is 20 times 6 is 120 concatenate
with seven and then we're going to add
on 8 and then we're going to multiply
that 59 so now we've got 23 plus 12 if I
want to do this all at once actually you
know I'll do that step there is a
concatenation plus 8 and then that
there's x 9 okay so let's let's so we
checked into the calculator now that
feels like it's obvious enough that we
can we can drive this home 1207 plus 8
equals unsurprisingly 1215 x 9 equals
that plus the 23 at the top equals ten
thousand nine hundred and fifty-eight
there it is so we have filled the gap
because the gap was only there because
people weren't taking concatenations
seriously and I I've taken it seriously
I filled the gap and I'm going to send
it in I'm gonna I'm gonna be like I
think I thought the gap it is it is now
available let me give you that really
that's the only reason I found this by
the way is because I wasn't afraid to
try something where the odds are i was
going to fail miserably and i said i
think that is the morale of the Parker
square right you give it a go even
though it's probably not going to work
and you embrace it you own it when it
doesn't work every now and then it does
work out for you
times that base have we worked out the
length or something well you use a log
right so is log base whatever the base is
of your next digit